hola de nuevo bueno en esta serie de
presentaciones voy a intentar mostrarte
o enseñarte todo lo que debes saber
sobre triángulos ángulos líneas
paralelas líneas perpendiculares todo
eso porque es información de la más
importante te lo prometo lo vas a usar
en todos tus cursos de matemáticas y
bueno una vez más una vez que aprendas
todas las reglas jugaremos algo llamado
juego de los ángulos vamos a empezar con
algunos conceptos básicos tú ya sabes lo
que es un ángulo bueno mejor voy a
asumir que no sabes lo que es un ángulo
y te voy a mostrar lo que es un ángulo
así que qué es un ángulo te voy a decir
si yo tengo dos líneas mejor voy a usar
una herramienta más así está mejor si yo
tengo dos líneas que se intersectan en
un punto el ángulo es la medida de
exactamente cómo o qué tan ancho es la
intersección entre esas dos líneas ajá
entonces es cómo voy a usar una mejor
herramienta aquí este es el ángulo un
ángulo es es que tan ancho se abren esas
dos líneas y se miden ya sea grados o
radiales
solo para simplificar las cosas vamos a
usar la notación de grados cuando
empieza a ver trigonometría bueno
aprender a radiales otra quizá sea bueno
aprenderlos desde hoy pero bueno
quizás ya estés familiarizado con esto 0
grados serían estas dos líneas una
encima de la otra esto así al tanteo son
aproximadamente 45 grados yo diría más o
menos si tuviera dos líneas aún más
apartadas formando así esto es un ángulo
recto son 90 grados aquí y las líneas
que forman un ángulo recto un ángulo de
90 grados son también llamadas líneas
perpendiculares porque bueno porque
bueno bueno porque ten ganas de decir
que por qué porque son perpendiculares
pero la razón es porque una está
completamente vertical mientras la otra
está totalmente horizontal entonces
están yendo como el bueno es difícil
explicar esto con palabras pero creo que
ya entiendes la idea por definición
líneas perpendiculares formar un ángulo
de 90 grados y de hecho las ves todo el
tiempo en todas partes por ejemplo en
cuadrados en rectángulos están hechos
por un montón de
rectos o líneas que se cortan en 90
grados entonces por ejemplo estas dos
líneas forman un ángulo recto y la
notación es usamos un cuadradito es
equivalente a hacer esto y poner aquí 90
grados de hecho puedes obtener ángulos
más grandes y exceden de los 90 grados
digamos que yo tengo
si yo tengo una línea así y tengo la
otra línea así horizontal
entonces yo sé que esto forma bueno que
se más o menos algunos 135 grados más o
menos am si quieres un día medir el
ángulo de verdad así puedes usar un
protector es una herramienta utilizada
para medir ángulos entonces aquí son 135
grados ahora las dos líneas bueno si dos
líneas parece que forman una sola línea
así esto es aquí están formando un
ángulo de 180 grados entonces tú puedes
ver que forman una línea de hecho si es
una línea aquí este ángulo mide 180 y
puedes puedes seguir si este ángulo mide
135 grados también puedes medir este
ángulo aunque bueno sería muy bueno
hacerlo en otro color para
agregar un poco de variedad ahí está
este ángulo este ángulo los ángulos en
un círculo un círculo tiene 360 grados
entonces si esto es de 135 grados este
ángulo en rosa mide 360 menos 135 grados
tiene sentido verdad entonces este
ángulo mide 360 menos 135 grados y eso a
que es igual eso es igual a 225 grados y
eso es lo que mide este ángulo en color
rosa lo puedes hacer bueno puedes hacer
más cosas aquí sabes que los grados de
un círculo son 360 grados eso es muy
importante es muy importante saber eso y
también es importante saber que si
recorremos la mitad de un círculo justo
como lo hicimos aquí eso es 180 grados
digamos que aquí están los extremos de
las dos líneas que forman esta sola
línea porque en realidad es solamente
una y si viajas un cuarto de distancia
del círculo eso es 90 grados entonces
bueno espero ya tengas un poco más de
intuición de sobre lo que son los
ángulos así que ahora te voy a enseñar
un montón de un montón de reglas básicas
y muy importantes para ángulos entonces
voy a borrar esto voy a borrar acá está
aquí y ahora pantalla negra es no aquí
acá ok
perfecto así bueno si yo tengo una línea
la voy a poner en color morado me gusta
usar colores para no aburrir entonces
aquí tenemos esta línea y bueno espero
hacer hacer esto de tal forma que tenga
sentido para ti lo que estoy haciendo
digamos que tengo un ángulo un ángulo
así formado por estos dos segmentos o
líneas y bueno digamos supongamos por
qué bueno no estoy segura no estoy dando
las medidas exactas entonces supongamos
que este es un ángulo de 30 grados y
sabemos que si recorremos todo el
círculo si recorremos todo todo el
círculo entonces sabemos que eso es
igual a 360 grados cierto pero bueno
aquí aquí dibuje ese ángulo de una
manera muy fea
bueno funciona y también sabemos que
este ángulo mide 330 grados si lo ves
por qué porque este ángulo más este otro
ángulo color rosa es igual a 360 330
grados más 30 grados es igual a 360
grados así que este ángulo mide 330
grados y bueno recuerda esto recuerda
que los ángulos en un círculo bueno hay
360 grados en un círculo ahora si alguna
vez tal vez tú alguna vez jugaste un
juego un juego llamado 720 ajá consistía
en que en que tú ibas en su patineta muy
contento y brincaba si giraba la
patineta dos veces
entonces había recorrido 720 grados
porque en un círculo si recorres sí si
giras bueno si recorres el círculo dos
veces eso es 720 grados o schiffrin casi
gira solamente una vez eso solamente son
360 grados ajá
pero bueno en team 360 grados en un
círculo es lo que escribí aquí arriba y
la mitad de un círculo es 180 grados
algo que también es importante como dije
si recorre
de un círculo esos son 180 grados pero
si tenemos dos ángulos que suman 180
grados por ejemplo aquí
voy a poner un poco más verde la línea
ahí está ok sí sí tenemos esto y aquí se
forman ángulo cierto entonces yo tengo
un ángulo ahí no estoy todavía con una
herramienta de línea entonces bueno ahí
está mejor sí tenemos este ángulo el
cual miren no sé qué llamémosle x
entonces este ángulo llamemos de x a
este otro ángulo
llamémosle ye y bueno que sabemos sobre
esta relación que sabemos sobre la
relación entre x y bueno sabemos que
todo este ángulo
sabemos que todo todo este ángulo el
cual es la mitad de un círculo cierto
mide 180 grados
entonces x mayer a cuánto es igual la
suma de estos dos ángulos x más entonces
bueno veamos x más james será am
bueno aquí quiero ser consistente con
los colores x más esto será igual a 180
entonces esto es igual a 180 grados o
podríamos escribir
y es igual a 180 menos x o también
podemos escribir x es igual a 180 menos
pero si x es igual a 180 grados tú
puedes ver que tiene sentido todo esto
si tú sumas ambos ángulos recorre la
mitad de un círculo eso nos dice que x y
jenson en esta palabra que viene a
continuación es una palabra bastante
elegante bueno para mi gusto en ok xy
son suplementarios suplementarios
ángulos suplementarios entonces te lo
tengo muy en mente esto se le llaman
ángulos suplementarios y suman si suman
180 grados entonces bueno ahora bien y
qué tal si tenemos una situación
y no se alinea no estoy usando la
herramienta de línea pero que ya está a
ver si ahora sí ahí está ok perfecto
entonces pensemos que tenemos esta
situación dibujo dos líneas
perpendiculares y aquí hemos recorrido
un cuarto del círculo cierto entonces
todo este ángulo este todo este ángulo
que se forma me quedó algo grande pero
bueno mide 90 grados ajá porque son
líneas perpendiculares y si yo tengo si
yo tengo una una línea que lo cortan en
dos ángulos llamemos a uno de ellos
llamemos a este x y a este otro ángulo
ya vemos leche entonces tenemos que x
massieu es igual a 90 grados y podemos
decir que x y ya son ángulos
complementarios complementarios así se
llaman ángulos complementarios porque
suman 90 grados ahora es importante que
no te no te confundas ángulos
complementarios suman 90 grados y
ángulos simplemente
suman 180 grados y bueno nos vemos
después bye